- Hi, I'm Finn Wolfhard.
- Hi, I'm Noah Schnapp.
- And I'm Millie Bobby Brown.
- And we're best friends.
- We're going to be doing the BFF test.
We are family, in this game.
This is the family test, let's go.
C'mon.
- Here we go.
- I don't, I actually
can't draw it though.
- Okay I'm gonna draw it better.
- By the way guys,
I've seen this on his phone before.
So--
- Ready?
- Hold on, hold on, hold on!
- You saw...
You're a cheater!
Turn it around, it's not the poop emoji.
You saw him.
- Go away!
- Okay me first!
- No!
Because you've sent this to me before.
- Heart eyes?
- The poop emoji.
- It's either the laughing one or
the smiley face.
- It's the smiley face.
- [Noah] I know Finn so well.
- I've seen the poop emoji on your--
- Yeah but it's like
how many times can I use
the poop emoji?
- You know what,
I'm disappointed in you Finn.
- Okay.
- Hey, hey.
- I'm looking up.
Why would I look at your answer?
- She knows I'm gonna say this,
but it could be something--
- I know, I know what you're gonna say.
- Okay I'm just gonna go with that.
- Okay.
Are we all showing?
- Yep.
Three, two, one.
- Please tell me.
- Milly Rock!
- Are you kidding me?
- Yes, go Finn!
Loving you.
- I know my family.
- You know your family.
- I was gonna say that,
but like I thought--
- Next.
- Okay, what's my fear?
- I know this is not gonna be it,
it's just funny.
(laughs)
How is yours Finn?
- I have no idea.
- It's not.
- I'm scared of sharks.
- Oh my God!
- Shark.
- Clif bars becoming extinct.
- I don't even like Clif bars.
- You love--
- That's old Millie.
- Oh okay.
- Me and Millie don't
even know each other.
- [Finn] Okay.
- Oh, me and Millie know this.
I mean, easy.
- Oh.
- Finn, that's definitely you.
- Me and Finn know this one.
- Great.
- We all agree on something.
- I have hosted a costume party before.
- You have.
- It was a Hallieween,
it was for Halloween.
- [Finn And Noah] Hallieween.
- Okay guys, you know what?
This is not the time.
It's happened to me before.
I'm not salty about it.
Yeah, okay cool.
Finn, I'm glad we agree.
- I do it to a lot of people.
- [Finn] Millie, she did it today.
(Millie laughs)
- I do do that a lot.
- See I'm not the only one.
- Oh, of the three of us?
Sorry.
He's insane with math.
Oh.
- I said no one.
- I said Finn.
- Noah, you're insane--
- I'm really bad at math.
- Please do not give yourself a bad rep.
You like, you look at a sum
and then you just know it.
It's insane.
Oh.
- It's not Clif Bars!
- Oh no, I know what it is.
The baby food...
GoGo Squeeze.
- Baby food, apple things?
- I didn't even answer.
- Yeah the baby food, apple things.
That's it, GoGo Squeeze.
That's right, we just did the BFF test.
- That's it.
See we did, okay.
- We did okay.
It was fun.
- Thank you so much for watching.